plus de taxes sur les carburants des
péages routiers un moratoire sur le
développement du réseau routier il faut
prendre les grands moyens selon
l'alliance de transit pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le secteur du transport transit c'est
l'alliance pour le financement du
transport collectif un groupe de
spécialistes dont fait partie florence
junca adenot professeure au département
d'études urbaines et touristiques de
l'université du québec à montréal madame
je cas de nos bons soir bonsoir
vous avez remis un rapport aujourd'hui
déposer un rapport une grande réflexion
qui appelle à une grande réforme de la
fiscalité notamment pourquoi parce que
le secteur du transport n'arrive pas à
réduire ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre en fait il ya trois problématiques
en même temps on va commencer par la
première qui est une problématique de
financement des transports au québec les
transports routiers et transports
collectifs sont financés avec la taxe
sur l'essence et la taxe sur
l'immatriculation et cette dernière
décroît a commencé à décroître
pourquoi parce que les études sont moins
énergivore il ya des véhicules
électriques et elle va continuer à
décroître
alors que en même temps les besoins pour
leur et d'entretien pour le réseau
routier qui est à 69 % à réparer et pour
le développement des transports
collectifs augmente alors ça c'est la
première dynamique
comment faire quoi faire et s'est
accentuée par le fait que les politiques
environnementales le gouvernement a
décidé de diminuer les ges de 37% alors
que le secteur des transports c'est le
mouton noir dans le sait il a lui
augmenté de 35% au cours des dernières
années donc la pression deuxième
pression s'exerce encore sur comment
faire pour diminuer l'auto solo est ici
possible diminue l'auto solo qui est
énergivore
puis si on met le troisième que l'on
examiné dans l'étude c'est la congestion
croissante dans l'est
milieu urbain après plus de 4 milliards
dans un jour de montréal ce que vous
dites dans votre rapport c'est qu'il y a
un travail à faire mais non oui pour
arriver à changer la tarification sur la
route mais que vous dites c'est que
maintenant on devra augmenter la taxe
sur le carburant et on devrait aller
vers des péages routiers également
c'est ce que vous proposez en bon état
exactement la combinaison des deux oui à
l'échelle du québec avec toutes les
modalités pour éviter de pénaliser parce
qu'il faut de l'équité sociale il faut
éviter de pénaliser géographiquement
toutes ses modalités la ont été
explorées dans d'autres dans d'autres
pays donc sont applicables ici on dit
pas que c'est la panacée en digue dans
les scénarios
ça fait partie des moyens qui sont vos
qui valent la peine d'être examinée par
ceux qui prennent des décisions de la
même façon que l' usage le partage de
l'usaj de la route fait partie des
mesures de déco fiscalité quand vous
partagez votre chaussée avec des voies
réservées que vous tarifés lusage delà
de la voie qui n'est pas aujourd'hui
sauf dans les centres urbains tarif est
ce qu'on fait on génère des revenus mais
aussi on amène à changer les
comportements des personnes qui se
mettent à réfléchir et qui disent ouais
ça me coûte ça est-ce que j'ai pas un
moyen alternatif que je pourrais prendre
est-ce qu'on ne vient pas viser des
ménages de la classe moyenne des ménages
qui vivent en banlieue des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à voir par exemple une
propriété sur l'est de montréal qui
doivent s'éloigner davantage
est-ce que c'est pas ces gens là qui
vont se trouvait à payer ses taxes là
mais tout le monde va se trouver à payer
cet axe là tous ceux qui ont des noms
des voitures ça vise pas une population
en particulier mais est-ce que je vais
prendre me faire l'avocat du diable
est ce que le monde tolérera longtemps
encore d'être pris dans la congestion de
perdre des heures de temps le 4
milliards que ça coûte ça coûte aux
citoyens et aux entreprises ça coûte en
perte de temps ça coûte un sac ou temps
d'utilisation de la voiture ça coûte 1
naissances gaspiller sa coûtant tout ce
que vous voulez c'est clair que dans le
rapport on aborde d'autres d'autres
domaines on l'y faut aussi éviter
l'étalement urbain il faut essayer de
rapprocher d'avoir des mécanismes
incitatifs en sens inverse pour que les
gens viennent s'installer plus proche
des pôles de transports collectifs plus
proche des milieux urbains
parce que ça va dans les deux sens
l'écofiscalité c'est pas juste
pénalisant ça peut être aussi incitatif
mais on a l'impression que de ce que je
comprends la du rapport que vous avez
présenté en tout cas avec quelques-unes
des propositions vous présenter on
travaille plus sur la pénalité sur la
punition puis on a l'impression que
l'encouragement au moins fonctionné en
quelque sorte
non là vous avez raison c'est un premier
dix ans la première perception mais pour
que ceux-ci marche il faut que ce soit
accompagné d'une offre majeur
d'investissement majeur en transport
collectif et que ce soit accompagnée de
travaux de maintien dans le réseau
routier de maintien en état qui est
lourdement actuellement lourdement pour
pénaliser et je vais prendre un exemple
concret
londres quand tu es là n'était pas
complètement congestionnée quand ils ont
décidé d'implanter un un ph tout autour
de la cité trois ans avant ils ont
investi d'un réseau de transport
collectif dans l'offre de transport
collectif pour que quand ça s'est
installé le monde avait les gens avaient
d'un choix puis le résultat c'est que
dans les deux années suivantes lusage de
l'auto a diminué de 35%
donc il faut pas que ce soit juste une
pénalité il faut soit accompagnée que ça
serve accompagner les solutions mais on
n'est pas loin on n'est pas là il faut
aussi rendre à un moment donné je dois
faire je comprends mais l'offre pour
nous encourager à bouger autrement la
mobilité au toit main
cette offre donne n'est pas là à côté de
ce qu'il faudrait faire pour atteindre
les objectifs à court terme et
finalement exactement c'est pour ça que
on développe et on dévoile les résultats
d'une étude qui dit qu'il faut faire
tout cela en même temps et de façon
cohérente et concertée et faire
attention aussi à l'équité sociale pour
de façon à ce que les retombées soient
pas punitive pour certains groupes par
rapport à domont fait attention à ça
parce que le citoyen qui part de
montréal à chambly qui fait 30 km il va
payer le péage routier 9 10 dollars par
jour il faut payer la taxe sur le
carburant de quelques dizaines de cents
de plus que ce qu'on a présentement
c'est ce citoyen qu'il va devoir payer
c'est ce citoyen comme d'autres citoyens
qui vont devoir payer mais c'est quoi la
solution au fait que les revenus qui
permettent d'entretenir les routes et de
développer transports collectifs sont en
décroissance on fait quoi
il faut trouver des alternatives et des
alternatives où on a les deux les trois
objectifs en même temps un l'argent la
diminution des gaz à effet de serre bien
diminution de la congestion faut
toujours les prendre les trois ensemble
alors oui
ça a un coût mais le coup de ne rien
faire celle qu'elle est leur votre
proposition vous la faites au
gouvernement du québec
nous on c'est une étude que l'on produit
des résultats
donc on les rend publiques mais moi
j'appuie sur un point on fait quoi
face à la diminution de nos revenus et
aux à la congestion croissante et au gaz
à effet de serre qui continue
d'augmenter
maintenant j'ai un cas de non merci
beaucoup merci merci